[Music]
he was a beloved and pioneering figure
as black history month comes to a close
we are paying tribute to sydney poitier
the oscar-winning actor who broke down
hollywood's color barriers died last
month at the age of 94. and tomorrow
night on b-e-t i'll be hosting sidney
poitier in his own words to honor his
life and legacy
in more than 55 films he played
characters with dignity and integrity
values poetier says he learned from his
parents
sidney poitier's improbable journey to
hollywood stardom began on cat island in
the bahamas a strip of land 46 miles
long and three miles wide
the youngest of seven children poitiers
was born three months premature while
his bahamian parents were in miami
selling tomatoes
poitier weighed just three pounds unsure
of his survival his father bought a tiny
casket while his mother consulted a palm
reader who shared a different fortune
she said don't worry about your son
he will survive
he will
walk with kings
by the age of 10 poitiers family moved
to the main island of nassau where he
dropped out of school and worked as a
child
i had quit school and i sought to go to
work you see i was working at the age of
12 and a half
when i was or was not working i was
running with a group of guys who were
imaginative
in nasa poitier's own imagination
flourished after he watched his first
hollywood movie a western
to keep him out of trouble his father
decided to send poitiers to live with
his brother in miami
then my sister teddy one day
said to me
what would you like to do with your life
when you get to america
i said i would like to go to hollywood
and work as a cowboy
i had no idea then that hollywood was a
place where films were made i thought it
was a place where there were lots of
cows
my father got me a passport
and he took me down to the boat on the
day that i left
and he put me on that
and he said
take care of yourself son
take care of yourself son so much of his
life was due to or the blessings in his
life were due to people
giving him
care and attention
just perfect strangers who who just one
even taught him how to read which
enabled him to go on and to read for
parts it's an amazing story story sidney
poitier in his own words it airs
tomorrow night at nine eastern on b-e-t
an immediate thought immediately
following to sir with love beginning at
9 30. we'll be right back